رح تنضم الينا في الاستوديو الطفله جنى
ابو ورده اللي قررت طبعا انه تتبرع بشعرها
على الهواء مباشره
ستشاركنا هذه التجربه صباح الخير يا جنى
طبعا جنى كم عمرك عشره عشره ما شاء الله
[موسيقى]
طبعا انتم ما تتخيلوا كم الناس الموجودين
في الاستوديو اللي بيتابعوا هاي اللحظه
[تصفيق]
نورنا
انا مش قادره اتخيل انه 17 سنه يعني في
هاي اللحظات شملناهم بهذا الفيديو هلا افت
بولر بتلعب كره قدم
ببريطانيا ومع المنتخب الاماراتي بتدرب
هون بالامارات
منظر مؤثر كتير اول شيء كل عام وانتم بخير
سعيده بتواجدي معكم
كل عام والعربيه والمتابعين بالف خير
سعيده ان اكون جزء من هذا الصرح يعني انا
لما نحكي عن يوميات ميسون انا بقدر اقول
انه هي استكمال وليست بدايه هي استكمال
لخطه كانت قبل ان كان بالام بي سي اللي
كانت اول محطه فضائيه
وهزت اذا فينا نقول قطاع الاعلام
ايضا
تطرقت الى مواضيع جدا كنا نعتبرها تابوهات
ولكن هذا بهدف التاثير ما يكون امتداد